I just want to get out you know as
quickly as I can and do whatever I can
you know to get out of there and that's
up
that's Real Housewives of New Jersey
star Joe Giudice opening up about his
upcoming 41 month prison sentence that
starts March 23rd in New Jersey the 43
year old was joined by his wife Teresa
for an exclusive sit-down interview with
ET on Tuesday at the Renwick Hotel in
New York City no topic was off limits
including potential deportation after
Joe's prison stay a subject that made
him emotional when you are done serving
your time there is a chance that you
could not be able to maybe come home and
you would be deported is there any truth
to that I mean yeah I mean there's a
chance of anything happened and you know
what I mean there's nothing that in life
that you know is certain but I mean you
know we'll deal with that when you know
when I get out how about the girls do
they know where you're going they go on
computers they know everything I mean my
daughter Milania tells me you're going
away for a lot more months to mommy
what do you think you'll miss the most
I'm not having her husband at home I
mean I'm gonna miss of course sleeping
with him at night and cuddling with him
and we're gonna miss the passion and I
can't say don't worry Joe said he'll
miss his family most while he's gone but
hopes to use prison as a way to
kick-start a healthier lifestyle I
haven't stopped drinking Malinois too
long so I could definitely use it just
for that you know then which is probably
gonna be a good thing for me health-wise
anyone where do you see your family in
five years from now when this is all
over it was all put behind you guys home
home what our gates closed cameras no
cameras no cameras for more from Teresa
and Joe's emotional interview tune into
ET Wednesday March 2nd
you